so let's talk a little bit about what's
probably not your favorite subject it's
definitely not mine and that is death uh
and uh it's not something a lot of us
think about and I remember when I was a
kid and I used to see these ads on TV
for life insurance and it used to Boggle
my mind I used to say why would
I don't even want to think about life
insurance and if I'm dead well you know
who cares you know I I won't need the
money anymore who are they going to pay
Etc and then I got married I had kids
and I completely got Wildlife Insurance
matters because once you have other
people in your life that you might be
helping support
then you do start to wonder if you care
about them you you wonder well if what
if something were to happen to me what
if I were to die we would have our loss
of income they might have other things
that they had they they might have to do
above and beyond that because maybe I'm
helping out at home and you're going to
need more support at home so you're
gonna have even more costs at the same
time that you have loss of income you
might have a mortgage to pay and the
last thing you want your family to have
to deal with if you die is not only
they're hopefully grieving for you a
little bit but they're also having to
move or they can't pay their house or
they're going to have to you know change
their standard of living in a
significant way
so as soon as I had kids I got a life
insurance policy now the basic idea of
life insurance is you pay a premium you
pay a certain amount every year and if
you were to die then the life insurance
company will pay whoever you say is the
beneficiary it's oftentimes someone's
partner or your children or some other
family member usually people that you're
already helping support in some way
and when I thought about how much life
insurance I needed I remember I first
got it when my first child was born I
think I was 30 32 years old at the time
I said well we have a mortgage I want at
the time we only had one kid I want him
to be able to go to college if something
were to happen to me so I got a policy
that was large enough that would uh be
able to pay off the rest of our mortgage
pay for his college education and then
maybe have a little bit extra to help my
wife support her if she needed extra
help with whatever it might be and so
that's how I thought about it more
recently I got another health insurance
sorry I got another life insurance
policy with that same idea I now have
three kids I want all of them I want to
be able to afford for all of them to go
to college I want all of uh you know I
want my wife and other folks in my
family that I take care of to still be
taken care of if I were to lose my
income so so or by dying there's other
ways for ensuring loss of income for
other reasons but this is by dying
now there's a couple of different life
insurance flavors that you can get the
biggest distinction is term life versus
whole life policy now term life
insurance only covers a certain number
of years you can get a term life policy
for say 10 years or 20 years while a
whole life policy will cover the rest of
your life you might be saying well why
would I ever want a term life when I
could get one that's whole life well it
turns out that a term life policy is
usually cheaper and why is that well if
you're say 32 years old like I was and
you got a 10-year Term Policy because
you're like okay over the next 10 years
my family's going to need help paying
the mortgage or whatever it might be or
let's say over the next 20 years if you
get a 20-year term
that could help cover my family through
college through the mortgage Etc and
then after that my kids are going to be
on their own they might not need it as
much and from an insurance company's
point of view if you look at a 32 year
old who's in good health and they say
the probability of them dying in the
next 20 years by the time they're 52 is
fairly low so we could uh we can give
them a pretty low premium so I I didn't
have to pay that much uh per per per
year now if you've got a whole life
policy back when you're 32 the insurance
company is going to say well Sal's going
to die eventually and it's just a matter
if he's going to die sooner or is he
going to die later and so they price it
accordingly so that even if you you know
when they pay it out you know maybe
you're 80 or 90 years old when you die
but that payout is still probably going
to be less than the amount that you put
in over the years especially if you last
till 70 or 80 or 90 years old because
not only are they taking those premiums
you're giving them but they're the
insurance company is investing it so
they're also getting uh they're getting
the the Returns on that premium so they
do the numbers they do the statistics to
see okay if someone let's say the
average life expectancy is 75 or 80
years old if they paid this premium all
the way to that and were able to invest
that premium are we going to get more
money than we have to pay out but
they're still probably going to ask for
more money for a whole life policy
because they have to do that in fact
almost always they'll ask more money for
a whole life policy than for a Term
Policy so you have to decide what you
what are you trying to de-risk what are
you trying to cover and then act
accordingly and you know one of the
things that's a little bit depressing as
you get older is I had gotten at the
time a 10-year Term Policy because oh
that'll cover my family and then once I
turned 42 and I wanted to get another
10-year policy well then it was a lot
more expensive and the reason why it was
a lot more expensive is well the
probability of a 42 year old dying in
the next 10 years is a good bit higher
than the probability of a 32 year old
dying in the next 10 years now there's
also this notion about insurability
because they're not just going to look
at your age they're going to look at
your health they're going to look at
your lifestyle if you like doing
dangerous things if if you have if if
you have things that increase your risk
of death well they're going to charge
you more and if it's if you lead a very
very risky lifestyle then they might not
insure you at all so that's this notion
of insurability when I got my last
health insurance someone came and
literally took test they checked my
blood pressure they checked my uh BMI my
body mass index to just kind of figure
out what the risk was and there's all
this you know questionnaire about my
lifestyle et cetera et cetera now the
last thing I'll talk about is and and
this isn't just applies to life
insurance but it definitely does apply
to life insurance which is the notion of
an individual plan versus a group plan a
group plan usually comes through say
your employer where your employer says
hey we're going to put give every
employee we have a life insurance policy
they might do other types of policies as
well and that's they're just paying
usually a fixed amount for every
employee
um and you know you're not they're not
the insurance company isn't trying to
differentiate because they're just
averaging everyone out sometimes they
might do a little bit of that
and
um that's nice it's a benefit you might
get from your employer but if you leave
your employer that policy might not be
effective anymore so if it was a life
insurance policy if you die after
leaving your employer well then it's not
going to be so beneficial while on the
other hand if you have an individual
plan one that you pay directly well
that's just going to be tied to you it's
not going to be tied to where you happen
to work
so if you're young you're probably not
thinking a lot about life insurance
maybe you want to talk to your parents
make sure they have life insurance they
might they may or may not appreciate the
conversation but it is an important
thing to think about if we want to make
sure those that we care about are taken
care of
um if anything really bad happens